you interacted with a stranger yes and
how this has resonated and it won't go
away it's it had a lot of power this
incident can you tell us about this well
it was it was odd I was on a travel
later one of those you know the ground
moves you along to the other side of the
airport and this guy conveyor belt
moving walkway travel later anyway
sounds like someone in this is being
paid by travel a tur yeah
[Laughter]
travel later pays my mortgage but I was
travel aiding in one direction and then
this guy was traveling towards me and he
just was like yo TIG what's up and and
then just went past me and I thought we
were gonna have a glance like a moment
or so yeah just like that's so funny cuz
normally people need or want more from
you and I looked back and he never
turned around again and I think about
him all the time and I'm just like who
person and yeah I just he's stuck in my
mind and people write in they'll be like
I think I'm the travelator guy or oh you
know I think it's my boyfriend he said
he saw you and I'm just like this guy
would never email and say it's me he
would be like yeah click turned me off
on the table so even if he were watching
right now and you could address him it
wouldn't do any good because I already
turned the TV off
[Laughter]
as I love his style yeah you're
attracted to his lack of need yeah
that's yeah what's up and he's gone he's
gone
you